GUYS HAVEN'T EVEN MET YET.
MAYBE IT WAS POMPEO.
MAYBE HE DOES HAVE THE MAGIC
TOUCH.
BUT, FIRST, JAMES COMEY
MIGHT WANT TO PULL THE PLUG
ON THAT BOOK TOUR NOW THAT
THE FORMER INVESTIGATOR
HIMSELF IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
FOX NEWS HAS CONFIRMED THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING COMEY'S
HANDLING OF HIS MEMOS
DESCRIBING HIS MEETINGS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A SOURCE SAYING THAT THE
DOJ'S WATCHDOG IS LOOKING
INTO WHETHER THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR LEAKED ANY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
LET'S GET INTO THE DETAILS
WITH ATTORNEY TOM DUPREE WHO
SERVED AS PRINCIPLE DEPUTY
SENT A ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
THE GEORGE W. BUSH
ADMINISTRATION PLUS
REPUBLICAN RON DESANTIS WHO
JOINS US FROM FLORIDA
TONIGHT AND STEVEN, A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
GENTLEMEN, IT'S GREAT TO SEE
ALL OF YOU.
STEVEN, LET'S START WITH YOU
HERE.
JIM COMEY AS FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR, PERHAPS THOUGHT
THAT, LOOK, I'M THE FBI
DIRECTOR.
I CAN DECLARE WHAT'S
CLASSIFIED AND DECLARE
WHAT'S NOT CLASSIFIED AND SO
IF I SHOOT THESE MEMOS OVER
TO PAL OF MINE AT COLUMBIA
LAW SCHOOL, NO BIG DEAL.
HE WILL GIVE THEM TO THE
PRESS AND IT WILL CAUSE A
BIG STIR AND MAYBE MY
REPUTATION BOLSTERED MAYBE
EVEN START A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
BUT, DOESN'T THIS MEAN THAT
YOU KNOW, COMEY COULD BE IN
HOT WATER NOW WITH THIS NEW
INVESTIGATION?
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
REALLY THE CASE, LAURA.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
EXACTLY WHAT WE KNOW HERE.
WE WON'T KNOW FOR SURE UNTIL
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
CONCLUDED ITS INVESTIGATION
ABOUT WHAT ALL THE FACTS ARE
FOR SURE.
BUT THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" HAS REPORTED THAT
THERE ARE ONLY TWO MEMOS
THAT COMEY GAVE TO HIS
FRIEND THAT HAD ANY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
ONE OF THEM HE WENT THROUGH
AND REDACTED OUT THE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
AND THE OTHER ONE WASN'T
CLASSIFIED AT THE TIME.
IT WAS ONLY CLASSIFIED LATER
ON.
SO IT SEEMS LIKE HIS COURSE
OF CONDUCT HERE WAS FAIRLY
INOFFENSIVE.
YOU CAN'T VERY WELL BLAME
HIM IF A DOCUMENT WASN'T
CLASSIFIED UNTIL A LATER
POINT IN TIME.
THAT KIND OF RETROACTIVE
LIABILITY, I THINK HE COULD
ARGUE IS UNFAIR.
>> Laura: TOM DUPREE IS
SELF-REDACTION LEGIT HERE?
HE CAN WE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT.
GET IT TO MY PAL GOING TO
GET IT TO THE PRESS.
I WILL GET MY BIG SHARPY AND
BLOCK OUT FOREIGN INTEL
NAMES.
>> EVEN COMEY'S DEFENDERS
WOULD ADMIT HE IS WALKING A
VERY FINE LINE HERE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CRIMINAL JEOPARDY AND
INNOCENT IS WHERE YOU DRAW
THE LINE WITH THE SHARPY.
MY GOODNESS.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO BE IN JIM
COMEY'S SHOES.
TRYING TO SEE IF HE LEFT
SOMETHING IN THAT SHOULD
HAVE GONE OUT THE DOOR.
THE NEWSPAPERRER GENERAL HAD
NO PATIENCE FOR ANDY MCCABE.
IS HE IN REAL TROUBLE HERE.
WE WILL SEE IF HE HAS ANY
CRIMINAL JEOPARDY THERE.
CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS, LET'S
REMEMBER WHAT JIM COMEY SAID
BACK IN JUNE OF LAST YEAR
WHEN HE WAS TESTIFYING ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT WHY HE
DECIDED TO TRANSMIT THOSE
MEMOS TO HIS FRIEND.
AND I THINK WE HAVE THE
SPOT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> MY JUDGMENT WAS I NEEDED
TO GET THAT OUT INTO THE
PUBLIC SQUARE.
AND SO I ASKED A FRIEND OF
MINE TO SHARE THE CONTENT OF
THE MEMO WITH THE REPORTER.
DIDN'T DO IT MYSELF FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS.
BUT I ASKED HIM TO BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THAT MIGHT PROMPT
THE APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
>> Laura: FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS, CONGRESSMAN.
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS HE
ALSO SELF-REDACTED AT LEAST
ONE OF THE TWO MEMOS.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THAT WAS MALICIOUS
LEAKING OF GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS.
I ASKED CHRISTOPHER WRAY
UNDER OATH IS IT APPROPRIATE
FOR FBI AGENTS TO LEAK THEIR
WORK PRODUCT TO THE PRESS.
AND HE SAID ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I DO THINK HE IS FACING
EXPOSURE BECAUSE SOME OF
THAT STUFF VERY WELL MAY
HAVE BEEN CLASSIFIED.
BUT, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THIS IS A GUY WHO TOOK THOSE
DOCUMENTS, HE WANTED TO
GENERATE A SPECIAL COUNSEL,
AND IT'S INTERESTING YOU
LOOK AT THOSE MEMOS, HE
ACTUALLY WRITES DOWN IN THE
MEMOS, I TOLD THE PRESIDENT
I DON'T LEAK.
THE FACT THAT HE IS WRITING
THAT IN THE MEMO THAT HE
DOESN'T LEAK TELLS ME
PROBABLY WAS A HABITUAL
LEAKER.
>> Laura: ACTUALLY, YOU
BRING UP A GREAT POINT,
CONGRESSMAN.
THIS IS FROM THE COMEY MEMO.
THIS IS FROM JANUARY 6TH.
RIGHT AFTER HIS FIRST
MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
HE SAID AND HE WROTE HE SAID
I WAS EAGER TO FIND LEAKERS
AND NAIL ONE TO THE DOOR AS
A MESSAGE.
THAT'S VERY DRAMATIC.
I SAID SOMETHING ABOUT IT
BEING DIFFICULT HE RELIED WE REP
BEING DIFFICULT HE RELIED WE REI
BEING DIFFICULT HE RELIED WE RED
WE NEED TO CREATE A NARROW
TIFER THAT WE NEED TO
INVESTIGATE HIM AND I
WORRIED SUCH A THING WOULD
BE MISCONSTRUED.
HE KEPT AS CONGRESSMAN
DESANTIS SAID, HE WENT OUT
OF HIS WAY A NUMBER OF TIMES
TO SAY TO THE PRESIDENT, HE
SAID, HE CLAIMS IN THIS MEMO
THAT I'M NOT A LEAKER.
YOU CAN TRUST ANDREW MCCABE,
HE IS A STAND-UP GUY AND I
DON'T LEAK AND MCCABE IS IN
YOUR CORNER.
MEMOS TO THE FILE WERE
WRITTEN BY PEOPLE TO DO
WHAT, STEVE?
TO DO WHAT?
>> I THINK PROBABLY TO
MEMORIALIZE THE CONVERSATION
SO THAT THERE CAN BE NO
DOUBT LATER ON IF IT COMES
UP WHAT EXACTLY WAS SAID AND
WHAT WASN'T SAID.
I THINK THIS COURSE OF
CONDUCT SHOWS THAT COMEY WAS
A BIT CONCERNED ABOUT A
POTENTIAL OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
HE KNEW THERE WAS A BIG
TROPHY ABOUT IT.
HE KNEW IT MIGHT BECOME
IMPORTANT LATER ON TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WAS SAID AND
WASN'T SAID.
HE WANT TO CONTEMPORANEOUSLY
DOCUMENT IT SO THERE WOULD
BE NO DOUBT.
>> Laura: ON JANUARY 6TH HE
WAS WORRIED ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTIFIABLE?
>> I THINK QUITE POSSIBLY.
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT HIS
WHOLE COURSE OF CONDUCT.
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU WORK
FOR THIS MAN?
IF YOU THINK HE IS
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE AWNGED
ARE SITTING THERE AND I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO STAYING
ON WITH YOU, AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD -- HE SAID WHAT YOUR
PLANS?
I ENJOY MY JOB.
I WOULD LIKE TO STAY ON.
THAT'S WHY MOLLIE HEMINGWAY
TODAY WROTE THIS WHOLE THING
SMELLS LIKE A BIG SET UP.
THE WHOLE MEETING TALKING
ABOUT THES TO YEA, RATTLE
TRUMP OR TRY TO RATTLE HIM.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TRUE.
THERE IS THIS THING AND
LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE SAYING.
THIS TOM, YOUR REACTION?
>> IT IS PUZZLING.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS JUST
GETTING STARTED AND ALREADY
THE FBI DIRECTOR IS
MEMORIALIZING FOR WHATEVER
HIS PURPOSES WERE.
>> Laura: YOU DON'T
MEMORIALIZE TO MAKE YOURSELF
LOOK BAD.
YOU MEMORIALIZE TO MAKE
YOURSELF LOOK GOOD.
>> I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
THIS IS EXCEEDINGLY UNUSUAL.
I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY OTHER
ADMINISTRATION WHERE A FEW
DAYS IN YOU HAVE SOMEONE
NEEDING TO CREATE THIS SORT
OF RECORD.
THERE IS UNUSUAL THINGS
GOING ON HERE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN
DESANTIS, THERE IS A COMEY
POINT IN THESE MEMOS THAT
TALKED ABOUT CNN.
I WANT TO READ IT HE SAYS I
SAID MEDIA LIKE CNN HAD
THEM.
THE MEMOS.
AND WERE LOOKING FOR A NEWS
HOOK.
I SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT
WE NOT GIVE THEM THE EXCUSE
TO WRITE THAT THE FBI HALLS
THE MATERIAL OR THAT'S
REDACTED, AND THAT WE WERE
KEEPING IT VERY CLOSE HOLD.
HE SAID HE COULDN'T BELIEVE
THEY HADN'T GONE WITH IT.
AND I SAID IT WAS
INFLAMMATORY STUFF AND THEY
WOULD GET KILLED FOR
REPORTING STRAIGHT UP FROM
SOURCE REPORTS.
AND THEN BING DIVO, JUST A
FEW DAYS LATER, CONGRESSMAN
DESANTIS, CNN RUNS WITH IT
AND THEN IT GETS PUBLISHED
ELSEWHERE.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE WERE
SAYING, AGAIN, THE WAY THIS
IS WRITTEN, THIS MEMO TO THE
FILE, I SAID CNN WOULD BE
CRAZY TO PUT -- I DON'T
KNOW.
IF YOU ARE WRITING A NOVEL
HERE, YEAH, THERE IS THE CNN
HEADLINE UNTIL CHIEF
PRESENTED TRUMP WITH CLAIMS.
RUSSIAN EFFORTS TO
COMPROMISE HIM.
WHERE DOOR THEY GET THAT
FROM?
WHERE DO THEY GET THAT
HEADLINE FROM.
>> JUST THINK ABOUT IT.
JIM COMEY THIS IS A GUY WHO
NEVER MEMORIALIZED ANY
WUFERTION WITH BARACK OBAMA.
HE NEVER DID WITH LORETTA
LYNCH.
EVEN THOUGH HE NOW SAYS
LORETTA LYNCH WAS
CONFLICTED.
IT WAS ONLY FROM DAY ONE
WITH DONALD TRUMP.
THAT MEETING TO ME IS VERY
FISHY.
JIM CLAPPER, I AND MOST OF
MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
BELIEVE IS THE ONE THAT
ACTUALLY LEAKED THE
EXISTENCE OF THE MEETING TO
CNN.
BUT, WHY WOULD COMEY HAVE.
>> Laura: HOW DO YOU KNOW
THAT?
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT?
>> BASED OFF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WHAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH AND THEY ALLUDE TO IT
IN THEIR REPORT.
BUT, THAT'S JUST OUT
INFERENCE I MAKE.
I HAVE THINK HE WAS THE GUY.
NOW, HERE'S THE DEAL, COMEY
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT IT'S NOT
NEWS WORTHY AT THE TIME THEY
NEEDED A HOOK.
WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE GIST THEM THE HOOK.
SO EITHER HIM AND CLAPPER
KNEW THIS TOGETHER OR MAYBE
HE WAS ACTING AT CLAPPER'S
SUGGESTION.
BUT HE PROVIDED THE HOOK FOR
THAT TO GO OUT AND WHEN IS
HE BRIEFING DONALD TRUMP ON
IT I ONLY TALKS ABOUT THE
ONE SALACIOUS ALLEGATION.
HE DIDN'T DISCUSS OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE DOSSIER.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ENTITLED TO YOU KNOW
ABOUT?
AND, YET, COMEY HID THAT
FROM HIM.
THIS THING SMELLS VERY BADLY
AND I THINK HE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: HE HAS TO COME
BACK TO CAPITOL HILL, DOES
HE NOT, STEVE?
I THINK THE POINT THAT
CONGRESSMAN DESANTIS IS
MAKING IS THAT WHEN YOU GO
OUT OF YOUR WAY TO BRING UP
THE DOSSIER AND YOU BRING
ONLY ONE OF THE INFLAMMATORY
ELEMENTS OF THE DOSSIER UP.
THAT'S ROCKET FUEL.
THERE IS A LOT OF OTHER
STUFF IN THE DOSSIER.
YOU BRING UP THAT ONE POINT.
AND WE KNOW NOW IN HINDSIGHT
THAT HE WAS USING THAT
PROFESSOR AT COLUMBIA TO
THEN GET INFORMATION OUT TO
THE PRESS.
SO HE HAD IT IN HIS MIND
COUPLE MONTHS LATER TO
DISSEMINATE STUFF TO THE
PRESS.
HE WANTED A SPECIAL COUNSEL
APPOINTED.
WHY WOULDN'T IT BE LOGICAL
NOW TO THINK HUH, MAYBE HE
AND CLAPPER CHATTED ABOUT
THIS.
YOU KNOW, WE GOT TO GET THIS
OUT.
I MEAN, TRUMP IS RATTLED
ABOUT THIS.
>> SET UP ARTIST IS ANOTHER
PERSON'S, YOU KNOW, WHISTLE
BLOWER.
HERE IS A LIFELONG
REPUBLICAN WHO WAS PROMOTED
BY REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS AND
WHOSE HANDLING OF THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
AT LEAST HIS PUBLIC HANDLING
OF IT ARGUABLY WAS VERY MUCH
TO CLINTON'S DETRIMENT.
GOT A MOTIVE TO -- I'M NOT
SURE THAT HE HAS GOT THE
MOTIVE TO DO THIS SET-UP JOB
THAT WE'RE SPECULATING
ABOUT.
>> Laura: HILLARY CLINTON
GOT OFF SCOT-FREE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION WAS TOTALLY
SCOCHESD ULTIMATELY.
THE IDEA THAT HE LIKE HELPED
HILLARY, I NEVER BOUGHT THAT
ARGUE:  HILLARY CLINTON IF
SHE WERE I DIDN'T KNOW ELSE
COULD BE IN JAIL RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT I'M SUGGESTING IS
THAT A PROSECUTOR WOULD JUST
SIMPLY ANNOUNCE WE ARE NOT
BRINGING CHARGES.
HE WOULDN'T GO ON TO SAY BUT
SHE WAS EXTREMELY RECKLESS.
>> Laura: BECAUSE SHE WAS.
HE HAD TO SAY THAT.
>> WELL, I'M NOT SURE.
I THINK YOU CAN MAKE AN
ARGUMENTLAWYER
>> Laura: HAMMERS
BLACKBERRIES?
>> SHOWS HE WAS NOT
PRO-CLINTON.
>> Laura: I SEE THIS AS
COMEY HAS SHOWN US IF HE
WANTS TO GET INFORMATION TO
THE PRESS HE WILL FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO DO IT.
NOW, THAT WAS A COUPLE
MONTHS LATER.
HE HATED DONALD TRUMP.
TODAY HE SAID ON AN
INTERVIEW OR YESTERDAY OH,
NO, I DON'T HATE HIM.
I DIDN'T EVEN DISLIKE HIM.
OH, PLEASE HE WALKED INTO
THAT TRUMP TOWER MEETING.
EVERYTHING ABOUT TRUMP HE
DESPISES, THE WAY HE CRESS,
THE WHY HE SPEAKS.
HE PROBABLY DOESN'T THINK HE
IS AS EDUCATED AS HE IS.
HE HAS YOU WILL.
HE IS A LUSH REPUBLICAN.
CONDESCENDING SUPERCILIOUS
AND PRIGGISH.
DONALD TRUMP IS A DIFFERENT
GUY.
>> ONE OF THE TRAGEDIES
HERE, LAURA, HISTORICALLY,
THE REASONABLE WHY THE FBI
HAS BEEN HELD IN SUCH ESTEEM
BY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THEY
HAVE BEEN VIEWED AS
INDEPENDENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.
WHAT JIM COMEY IS DOING NOW
UNDERCUTS THAT WHAT IT IS IS
PORTRAYING A FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR AS A PARTISAN
ACTOR, AS SOMEONE WHO HAS A
POLITICAL AX TO GRIND.
HE IS GOING TO BE THE TALK
SHOWS AND TAKING PERSONAL
JABS AT THE PRESIDENT.
IT MAY BE SATISFYING TO HIM
AND PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE
THE PRESIDENT.